[Musique]
tout en cauchemar pour les 6500
étudiants du collège dansions de mariage
été témoin de coup de feu lorsque je
suis arrivé au square espagne il ya
encore des périmètres de sécurité
partout semblait faire un repérage du
secteur on va refaire des tournées comme
ça pour s'assurer que tout est correct
j'étais encore à l'opération d'urgence
évidemment tout le commandement de la
police de laval et si donc tous les
effectifs sont sur place je sais pas
pourquoi je suis vivant ma voiture
allait tomber dans le trou c'est pas la
première fois que geneviève jeanson se
retrouve au coeur d'une histoire de
dopage chez soi il conteste un contrôle
positif subi cet été lors du tour de
tout nord aux états unis mais
entre-temps elle est suspendue elle dit
car ils avaient déjà commis une première
effraction en 2004 un blizzard soudain
sur l'autoroute et et en quelques
secondes
un carambolage monstre de plus de 60
véhicules a provoqué des rafales jusqu'à
5 latvala
selon la sûreté du québec qui s'agit du
plus important carambolage à survenir au
québec on apprend que saddam hussein
pourrait être inhumé à ramadier c'est un
des bastions de la rébellion sunnite
plutôt que dans son village natal près
de tikrit la mort de saddam hussein ne
signifiera pas la fin de la violence en
irak six ans après cette rude série du
sud liban et l'armée israélienne et
andry en force sur le territoire
libanais des caricatures qui ont mis le
monde de l'islam en ébullition le
vatican a condamné lui aussi la
publication des illustrations soulignant
que la liberté de pensée et d'expression
n'autorise pas aux français les
convictions religieuses de quiconque
notre tête du côté des bars où ça sera
un peu plus délicat où l'eau les fumeurs
ont un peu plus de difficulté peut-être
est passé de la cigarette en prenant un
verre
on a surnommé le magnifique mais à 40
ans mario lemieux ne pouvait plus suivre
le riz il quitte locke et sans regrets
mais avec tristesse
[Musique]